In the wake of Donald Trump's completely depraved
and deplorable Maskell's stunt at the White
House Monday evening after leaving the hospital
with Corona virus, Jack Holmes wrote a very
good piece in Esquire about really what is
the urgent decline of America and the pressing
imperative to remove Donald Trump.
And he really hits many important points that
I want to talk about.
Jack writes in his piece, quote, We have been
heading down this road to ruin for some time
now, but the end stages are somehow uglier
and more empty than seemed possible.
And he adds that, quote, If you were looking
for a portrait of an American empire in decline,
it arrived Monday evening when Donald J. Trump,
in the thick of a bout with Kovik, 19, checked
himself out of the hospital at Walter Reed
National Military Medical Center and was flown
back to the White House on Marine One.
Going on to say that, quote, he climbed the
curved staircase, reached the balcony and
removed his mask in what appeared to be a
gesture of defiance of what the media, the
deep state scientist's reality itself.
It was not immediately clear, but that trademark
pout was unmistakable.
This was authoritarian chic.
The president was looking at something very
strongly, that's for sure.
Though it will not be an ounce of humility
or growth as a human being.
After he was struck by the very disease he
so long downplayed and ignored at the cost
of so many American lives.
And this article, which I would encourage
you to read, outlines the mockery that Donald
Trump has made of personal responsibility
and how actions have consequences.
The excesses of empire, the delusions of grand,
dour.
But I'd go even further.
Donald Trump has completely undermined the
executive branch of the United States.
He's undermined the Justice Department.
He's undermined science and education and
the people of America and common sense.
He's undermined and and really eliminated
the status of the United States as a worthy
participant in the experiment of humans on
planet Earth.
That is the degree to which this man has debased
Homo sapiens on this planet.
We are now a joke and we are pitted by the
world now.
It's not you know, for a while they were merely
laughing.
When I now hear from our friends in other
countries, they are scared for for us and
for themselves.
And they pity us and we are the danger.
Corrupt leaders the world over are enjoying
the catastrophe that is the world under Trump.
While our historical allies in Western democracies
are horrified and they're desperate for a
change, for a return to normalcy, and part
of the problem, part of this rapid decline
has to be accounted for in the more than 60
million who voted for Trump in 2016 and the
likely more than 60 million that will vote
for him again this November.
So we often talk about Trump, the people under
Trump, the people who work for Trump, the
Kaili MacKean nannies and the Sean Spicers,
they deserve to never work again because of
what they've participated in.
But what about the 60 million Trump lists
that are part of this debasement?
What happened to supposed Christian values
on the Republican side?
I guess it was just B.S.
They were blowing smoke.
Can't Republicans see a man who is lying to
them all the time for his own purposes as
not in line with what they claim to be about?
Do they see it and not care?
Is there that much cognitive dissonance taking
place?
Consider how absurd the hospital stunt was.
Notice that Trump came home from the hospital
with the orange face after having the white
face for a few days while at the hospital
because he wasn't getting the makeup contagious
with covered.
Trump had his makeup done by someone at the
hospital.
The micro is pathetic and the macro is simply
dystopian.
How much more of this can we take?
Unfortunately, the right seems more than willing
to take much more of it.
I spotted this comment on a right wing, on
Clave, on the Internet, reacting to the Trump
photo op propaganda video.
When he came back from the hospital, they
said, quote, People on the left are going
to lose their minds.
This is going to be so fun to watch.
That is emblematic of what we are fighting
right now.
It's not about conservative values.
If you actually look, you don't have to agree
with them.
But if you just find sort of like a normal
traditional conservative, they have essentially
nothing in common with Donald Trump.
This isn't about economic policy.
This isn't about social policy.
It's about angering the left.
As they said, the left is going to lose their
minds over Trump flying back from Walter Reed
in a helicopter.
They want to own the Libs trigger the left,
as they like to say.
So Democrats must win in a landslide this
November.
If we are to avoid a chance of another four
years of this and probably Democrats need
to win in a landslide.
I hate to say this, but to avoid the violence,
I fear we will see if it's close.
And Trump says it was rigged and I really
won.
We need a landslide to avoid the violence
as well.
The window of opportunity is closing.
Here we are now.
Just what is it, 27 days to go?
As of today, barely to a 26 and a half days.
The window is closing and we have a real opportunity
here.
And fortunately, Joe Biden is actually starting
to help his own cause.
And I want to talk
about
that next.